[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ses points de vue c'est
un plaisir de vous retrouver comme
chaque soir entouré de deux invités pour
livrer leur point de vue sur l'actualité
bonsoir gabriel cluzel vous êtes la
rédactrice en chef du site boulevard
voltaire un site d'information situé et
résolument à droite et vous êtes aussi
essayiste et auteur de enracinée nous
sommes tous deux héritiers publié aux
éditions arte dont soir gilles smadja
bonsoir vous êtes le directeur de
cabinet du maire de nanterre vous avez
été journaliste dans une vie antérieure
à l'humanité et
conseiller au cabinet de marie george
buffet la ministre communiste de la
jeunesse et les sports c'était donc sous
lionel jospin sous lionel jospin premier
ministre
nous n'allons pas parler politique en
tout cas pas tout de suite on va
commencer par s'intéresser aux vaccins
nous n'en avons pas s'est il nous en
faut plus c'est le cri qui monte de tous
les gouvernements en tout cas en europe
après que pfizer biotech puis
astrazeneca est annoncé qu' il n'allait
pas être en mesure de livrer autant de
vaccins que prévu tout ceci commence à
mécontenter très fort or sous la van der
leyen la présidente de la commission
européenne qui achète pour tous les pays
de l'union les dix vaccins écoutez là
c'était hier
l'europe a investi des milliards pour
aider à développer le premier vaccin
contre le coc vie de 19 pour créer un
véritable bien commun mondial et
maintenant les fabricants doivent livrer
honorer leurs obligations et c'est
pourquoi nous allons mettre en place un
mécanisme d' expertise sur la
transparence de la vaccination
si vous vous souvenez mais corps cela
vaudra d'ailleurs avait été nommé on
s'était réjoui en dix ans elle parle
français couramment mais apparemment
elle a oublié parce qu' elle ne parle
plus du tout là c'est l'anglais au rien
mais c'est pas le sujet du jour gilles
smadja les laboratoires 10
on n'arrive pas à livrer est-ce qu'ils
sont responsables est ce que ces big
pharma qui qui n'est pas à la hauteur
c'est la faute aux laboratoires
effectivement parce que les laboratoires
on ne respecte pas certain nombre
d'engagements si on en croit ce que nous
disent les
les dirigeants de l'union européenne
mais c'est la faute aussi beaucoup de
ceux qui ont négocié avec les
laboratoires
parce que quand l'union européenne a
annoncé en novembre avoir signé des
contrats avec les laboratoires sur la
production je crois de 300 millions de
doses
ce qu'ils n'ont pas dit c'est le prix
auquel ils ont payé ces vaccins et le
prix auquel ils ont payé ces vaccins il
est nettement inférieur à celui par
exemple payé par les états unis par la
grande bretagne par israël et par
d'autres les l'union européenne à payer
chaque dose je parle du principal vaccin
actuellement utilisés c'est à dire
faille there be
tech chaque dose aux environs de 12
euros la grande bretagne 17 euros les
etats unis 21 euros et israël 22 euros
est la conséquence de cela c'est que
ceux qui ont payé le plus ont été livrés
le plus vite et en plus grande quantité
c'est un sujet tellement sensible que
les labos ont imposé dans les contrats
avec l'union européenne une totale
confidentialité sur la question du prix
et des délais de livraison et c'est tu
sais la secrétaire d'état belge au
budget madame deblicker qui
volontairement ou pas a fait fuiter en
publiant sur son compte twitter
les prix auquel la belgique c'est à dire
l'union européenne à payer ces vaccins
et donc voilà pourquoi on en est là
aujourd'hui c'est à dire que en fait on
est dans une logique exclusivement
financière
les laboratoires livre d'abord à ceux
qui payent le plus cher et on mesure à
quel point entre parenthèses ceux qui
ont considérablement affaibli la
capacité de production française sur la
production de médicaments et de vaccins
en particulier on voit où ça nous mène
aujourd'hui on est en situation de
dépendance et c'est évidemment c'est
évidemment très grave parce que moi je
le vois dans la ville où je travaille
les gens ne comprennent pas cette
situation il ce qu'ils comprennent 10
ans s'inscrit à nanterre pour être
vacciné vous leur donnez rendez vous
quand elle actuellement au centre de
vaccination de nanterre il faut un délai
minimum de 7 8 semaines voire plus de
deux mois pour avoir un rendez-vous
quand on a 75 ans et plus ou qu'on est
dans une maladie a présumé à risque
voilà c'est ça que tu helmand le délai
ce qui fait qu'il ya des milliers de
gens aujourd'hui qui veulent se faire
vacciner et qui ne peuvent pas se faire
vacciner alors qu'on est dans une course
de vitesse c'est ça que les gens ne
comprennent pas à guillaume il faut ça
il faut le mesurer c'est qu'on est dans
une course de vitesse entre d'un côté
l'épidémie qui continue de progresser et
de l'autre la vaccination qui apparaît
comme la seule issue possible pour
espérer retrouver une vie normale donc
il faut vacciner le plus grand nombre de
gens le plus vite possible et on n'y
arrive pas ou alors pour compléter votre
propos
je voudrais envoyer nos internautes vers
une interview qu'a donnée le patron
d'astrazeneca astrazeneca ce une
entreprise suez deux britanniques mais
le patron est français il s'appelle
pascal soriot et et il a expliqué dans
le figaro à propos qui n'est pas
exactement le même que le vote pour ça
que je le donne puis après l'internaute
se fera son opinion en dix ans mais nous
nous livrons les gens qui nous ont
commandé en premier est dit les
britanniques ils ne sont pas ses
commandes trois mois avant le reste de
l'europe et donc c'est normal qu'on les
livres avant et pour le reste c'est pas
parce que on ne vend plus cher à
d'autres c'est ce qu'il y ait un jeu
mais c'est parce que on n'a pas assez de
vaccins parce que jamais dans l'histoire
de l'industrie pharmaceutique on avait
demandé de produire autant de vaccins
gabriel cluzel votre point de vue est ce
que c'est la faute à big pharma alors
c'est là c'est la faute à big pharma
d'une certaine façon parce qu'évidemment
ce sont ce ne sont pas des entreprises
philanthropiques d'ailleurs je peux on
peut remarquer que deux camps disait
jusqu'à présent on avait l'impression
nous on disait c'est comme si on avait
assassiné pasteur voyez il fallait faire
semblant de croire que tous ses
laboratoires dans cette course au vaccin
était absolument désintéressé je
caricature à peine ils n'étaient là que
pour travailler pour la santé des ans ce
qui est on voit bien que ce n'est pas le
cas parce que malheureusement
malheureusement la france mais d'autres
pays et l'europe avec elles ont laissé
ce pan de souveraineté parce qu'on se
rend compte que la santé ça fait partie
de la souveraineté et il paraît fou
d'ailleurs qu'on ne l'ait pas anticipé
avec parce que j'imagine qu'on anticipe
les gars bactériologiques et ce genre de
choses qu'on n'ait pas anticipé que
cette souveraineté allez nous manquer on
l'a laissée aux mains d'entreprises
année supranationale capitaliste comme
vous voulez qui évidemment sont appâtés
par le gain
on ne peut pas exclure le fait qu' ils
organisent des pénuries ça c'est fait
pour d'autres médicaments et que deux et
que de fait ils servent ceux qui ont
on régler le plus vite peut-être mais le
plus cher aussi là encore ils ne sont
pas l'enfant naturel de l'abbé pierre et
d'oeufs et de mère teresa mais les
gouvernements ont évidemment péché par
naïveté par naïveté par inaction alors
c'est un peu la pauvre ursula von der
leyen
c'est un peu compliqué parce que
l'angleterre qui est sortie de l'europe
alerte se débrouiller vite et mieux donc
évidemment c'est un peu un pour cette
question là voilà donc évidemment pour
elle c'est c'est c'est pas très bon
alors vous avez parlé de ceux de se
presser pdg là mais il y en a un autre
celui de modern à qui s'est exprimé sur
une chaîne de télé au suc et français
centralien et qui a expliqué que c'est
pas inintéressant parce que ça rejoint
ce que disait tout à l'heure que les
états unis avaient parié sur le lac
sainte ode à parier sur le vaccin à
partir du moment où on parie sur le
vaccin
il pouvait peut-être y avoir d'autres
choix mais il se trouve que la france
elle aussi l'europe à parier sur le
vaccin on a fait l'horizon indépassable
et le l'alpha et l'oméga donc après faut
s'en donner les moyens et les états unis
semble-t-il dès l'été on parier sur la
réussite de ce vaccin en investissant et
en permettant au laboratoire c'est en
tout cas ce que dit la pdn moderna de
construire l'outil industriel
alors que la frôler les la france est
désemparé la france et l'europe elle
elle n'a pas permis de dit-il de 2,2
comment dire de reconstruire cet outil
industriel notamment de mettre à l'abri
de protéger les matières premières
d'embauché enfin tout cela n'a pas été
fait donc aujourd'hui elle se retrouve
gros jean comme devant alors évidemment
on peut accuser les laboratoires on a
raison de le faire mais il est évident
que l'europe et la france ont pêché
fortement par naïveté je vais vous
passer la parole à gildas dans quelques
instants
je voudrais d'abord la donner aux
internautes précisé parce que peut-être
que cette expression est un peu absconse
que quand on vit big pharma
c'est une expression qui vient de la
gauche d'ailleurs et qui définit
qui stigmatiserait aujourd'hui
l'industrie pharmaceutique comme étant
une sorte d'oligopole préoccuper
uniquement de profits et pas forcément
de la santé publique même si pour parler
de louis pasteur fonds publics pasteur
est aussi un homme qui a gagné beaucoup
d'argent
pas avec ces vaccins mais avec la
pasteurisation c'est à dire le fait de
pouvoir fabriquer des conserves des
boîtes et il avait breveté tout ça et ça
lui rapporter des sous donc on peut être
un grand chercheur est aussi aimé un peu
l'argent mais c'est pas le sujet du jour
sur twitter les laboratoires sont ils
responsables du retard des vaccins est
assez partagée c'est plutôt oui à 57 %
et alexandre sur youtube vous fais
remarquer à juste titre que le sondage a
reçu des résultats partagés ce qui
n'arrive pas souvent
même s'ils ne sont pas responsables à
100% c'est évident qu'ils le sont au
moins en partie alors le débat vraiment
fait rage chez nos internautes jo sur
twitter oui les labos sont responsables
ils ont été subventionnés par l'union
européenne
ils ont le devoir de se débrouiller pour
produire suffisamment rapidement
florian au contraire les défend toujours
sur youtube les laboratoires ils sont
responsables de l'existence d'un vaccin
merci à eux déjà gaulle mort sur twitter
considère que ce sont avant tout des
problèmes de logistique qui se pose ce
n'est pas la faute des labos et enfin
micheline sur youtube qui estime que les
laboratoires sont tellement préoccupés
par le désir de faire de l'argent sur
ses vaccins qui ne parviennent pas
honorer les commandes la santé des gens
leur importe peu c'est à celui qui paye
le plus violent a beaucoup d'autres
beaucoup d'autres commentaires notamment
celui de babineau qu'on salue sur
lefigaro.fr qui rappelle qu'israël a mis
les moyens financiers effectivement ils
la paient plus cher israël vous le
disiez à l'instant gilles et que donc il
a été mieux servis en termes de vaccins
et puis ma riquiqui c'est sans doute un
pseudonyme sur lefigaro.fr qui se
demande si ça va finir comme les masques
avec bagarre à la sortie des labos pour
capturer les rares dos fabriquer six
matches à ce que cette situation je
crois révèle sait dans quel état assez
quand même désastreux nous sommes
aujourd'hui de dépendance sur une
question qui s'appelle pourtant la
politique de santé publique c'est à dire
qu'il ya un pan entier de la politique
de santé publique n'est plus du tout
public qui est entièrement entre les
mains de grands groupes privés comme ça
c'est partout donc laissons ces ya des
labos privés qui ont trouvé le vaccin
il n'y a pas de l'administration oui
mais sauf que la france et l'union
européenne en grande partie ont perdu
toute capacité à peser sur les choix des
laboratoires c'est à dire qu'en fait ces
grands groupes font absolument ce qu'ils
veulent
et là la logique de ces groupes c'est
une logique aujourd'hui exclusivement
financière c'est-à-dire sanofi par
exemple groupe français sanofi c'est le
troisième groupe français à verser le
plus de dividendes à ses actionnaires
derrière le groupe total c'est à dire
que pour sanofi ça va très bien merci
et pourtant qu'est ce que viennent que
vient d'annoncer sa nofilia il ya une
semaine la suppression de 400 postes en
particulier dans la recherche et dans le
développement sanofi qui vient
d'annoncer ça arrive c'est parce qu'ils
étaient trop dispersé oui oui la
suppression de 400 postes
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui il faut voir
que c'est la logique de ces groupes
c'est d'avoir choisi d'exporter
massivement d'externaliser massivement
ses productions ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui la pharmacie du monde
c'est la chine et l'inde 80 % des
médicaments sont fabriqués en chine
aujourd'hui c'est à dire qu'on les états
pour leur politique de santé publique
n'ont plus aucune capacité d'action
autonome si vous le voulez bien
on va quitter un petit peu ce sujet des
vaccins mais restait dans le traitement
de la pandémie pour parler d'un re
confinement possible le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriela talent a tenu des
propos plutôt alarmistes tout à l'heure
à la sortie du conseil des ministres en
expliquant que le couvre-feu je cite ne
freine pas suffisamment le virus et que
je cite encore le convainc confinement
très serré était à l'étude
question gabriel cluzel est ce que
pensait que les français pourront
supporter un nouveau confinement sk des
risques de voir des actes de
désobéissance civile on voit des
mouvements qui émergent qui sont assez
marginaux pour l'instant mais qui ont un
certain succès notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux de jeu ne meurent confinerait
pas
et puis on voit monter certains
galeristes dit mais je ne suis pas dans
les petits papiers de l'elysée que
là peut-être que le gouvernement a un
petit peu reculer au moins la date de
son annonce et même le chef de l'état
s'est un peu en porte ce serait un peu
emporté contre le conseil scientifique
qui lui propose que le confinement le
confinement leur confinement
parce que sans doute sont-ils bien qu'
il ya une grande qu'ils mentent en
france et ailleurs alors c'est vrai
qu'en france elle et elle est liée sans
doute alors je ne sais pas si elle sera
dure à dents dans les faits c'est
difficile de savoir si si la lal ce qui
se passe sur les réseaux sociaux peut se
traduire dans les faits mais enfin je un
président qui a vécu là la crise des
gilet jaune ne peut pas en faire fi et
doit évidemment se préoccuper et deux de
ses signaux
alors je crois que ce qu'a dit votre
internaute tout à l'heure et tout à fait
intéressant il disait il ya également un
problème logistique et d'organisation
parce qu'évidemment tous les pays ne
sont pas logés à la même enseigne
donc ce n'est pas seulement la faute des
laboratoires c'est aussi la gestion de
chaque pays
donc la france ne s'est pas d'éprouver
débrouiller alors certes on peut dire qu
israël ils sont un peu dans un état de
guerre une économie de guerre permanent
soit extrêmement cultivée très voilà il
ya une adhésion forte bon mais le fait
est qu'on voit bien que la la la gestion
chaotique de cette crise qui fait que
finalement les sentiers les français ont
le sentiment qu'une fine est ce sont eux
qui seront punis parce que peut-être le
gouvernement n'a pas su gérer bien ça
décuple un mécontentement une forme
d'aidé primé puis et puis une peur pour
l'avenir elle envie de se dire bon bah
le le gard moment il faut que tout ça se
termine parce qu'on veut pas passer dix
ans dans le confinement peut-être que
qu' il faut il faut trouver autre chose
donc ça je crois qu évidemment le long
sans quelques signes le gouvernement
doit être le confirme en perpétuelle
schisme a besoin je reviens au au sujet
de se re confinement possible je le
disais vous êtes le directeur de cabinet
du maire d'une grande ville il ya
combien d'habitants à nantes est 100
mille cent mille
comment est ce que vous sentez la
population est ce que vous voyez des
détentions à ce que le couvre feu
respecté
est ce que ça vous inquiète cette
perspective impressionné par le niveau
de respect des mesures et notamment du
couvre-feu des fermetures de commerces
seul à 18 heures etc je suis
impressionné par sa et jeu et
franchement je ne crois pas du tout à
l'idée que hergé
au contraire je pense que nos
concitoyens ils veulent ils veulent
absolument finir avec cette situation
ils veulent en finir avec cette
situation et si le prix à payer pour en
finir
c'est d'avoir une période la moins
longue possible d'un confinement qui
permette réellement de faire baisser
tous les indicateurs et de repartir et
surtout de gagner la bataille de la
vaccination dans le même temps je pense
que nos concitoyens sont prêts la ligne
à ne pas franchir
c'est la question du travail il faut
absolument que les gens puissent
continuer à aller travailler
ça fait ça c'est la ligne oui non mais
je parle de ceux qui sont autorisés à
l'activité économique et les écoles n'y
a pas de doute pour vous on les laisse
moi je moi je pense qu'il ya aujourd'hui
voilà si si c'est vrai que ce que ce que
ce qu'ils voulaient ce qui est le plus
aujourd'hui mal vécu c'est le yoyo
permanence nadir up allez on repart et
on recommence on savait qu'on reparle
je vous livre pendant deux 2 point de
vue de désarmer puis après on va changer
de sujet même si on reviendra sans doute
sur la situation sanitaire dans les
semaines à venir et notamment sur ce
confinement nouveau qui se profile le
point de vue de plop plop décidément de
très créatif en matière de pseudonymes
ces temps ci sur youtube qui considère
que les laboratoires ne sont pas
responsables
il livre au plus offrant comme ça
l'avait été pour les masques ajoute-t-il
et puis et ni sur youtube pourquoi la
france ne fait elle pas appel à la
russie pour avoir leurs vaccins spoutnik
5 c'est vrai qu'il ya un vaccin russie a
aussi un vaccin chinois avec cinq
chinois ils s'exportent bien certain
nombre de pays qui sont amis de la chine
je sais pas si c'est le cas du vaccin
russe en tout cas ce qu'ils attendent
c'est que celui ci n'a pas été validée
par les autorités de santé européennes
on change quand la hongrie la grèce la
hongrie qui ne déteste pas assez
régulièrement faire cavalier seul en
europe
sur ce sujet comme sur d'autres
apparemment parlons si vous le voulez de
cette enquête préliminaire qui a été
ouverte contre le mouvement politique
classé à l'extrême droite génération
identitaire enquête préliminaire pour
provocation publique à la haine raciale
cet organisme a monté il ya quelques
jours une opération spectaculaire à la
frontière entre la france et l'espagne
l'objectif est de dissuader les migrants
d'entrer en france par un certain nombre
de signaux publiques des des calicots
qui sont eux qui sont ouverts d
manifestation comme ça c'est
spectaculaire ça ne plaît pas du tout à
gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'intérieur qui ne cachait pas hier que
si cet organisme était dissous ce serait
pas plus mal
j'ai effectivement été particulièrement
scandalisé par le travail
si j'ose dire de sape de la république
des militants de génération identitaire
qui ne sont pas à leur premier coup
d'éclat
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire j'ai
donc demandé aux services miss intérieur
de réunir les éléments qui permettraient
aux mini that her 2 proposera des
solutions de génération identitaire je
sais que le ministère y travaillent il
le fera évidemment dans le cadre des
lois et des règlements de la république
génération identitaire gabriel usa alors
je pense que gérald darmanin s'engage
dans une voie périlleuse et il a tort je
pense de s'engager je ne sais pas quel
objectif il poursuit rs qu' il veut
montrer que dans sa loi dans sa lutte
par exane loi contre le séparatisme il
ne s'attaque pas que c'est un côté mais
qu' il est capable de s'attaquer à
l'extrême droite je n'en sais rien est
ce qu'il est agacé qu'on lui mette le
nez devant le fait qu'il ya un vrai
problème avec les frontières dans ce
pays que finalement ils aient la
question migratoire reste prégnante est
extrêmement préoccupante pour les
français sans que ce gouvernement
n'arrive rien à faire je ne sais pas
mais je crains que ce soit très
périlleux parce que je ne vois pas bien
comment il pourrait y arriver
donkey cci risque de se prendre un grave
camoufler puisque on sait bien que pour
l'opération précédente que c'est une
rationalité fr il y avait eu des
tentatives de poursuite ils avaient été
relaxés
il est temps les halles voilà hélas
cette fois c'est dans les pyrénées il ne
commet diaries ne font pas de violence
il ya pas de dégradation c'est pas les
black blocks
ils ne sont pas provocateur il brûle pas
des drapeaux français bien sûr
évidemment comme l'a fait line diana on
peut pas on peut pas imaginer que
certaines certaines associations
extrêmement provocatrice 1 je rappelle
que là les ailes dna a récemment traité
nos seuls alain de défense noire
africaine afin que ça a dit que nos
soldats morts au mali étaient des
terroristes donc tous et toutes ces
officines sont tolérées et on viendrait
comment dire interdire génération
identitaire parce que finalement ils
sont des lanceurs d'alert sur
l'immigration on peut ne pas apprécier
la méthode le fait est qu'ils ne font
rien d'illégal et que il met le doigt
sur un sujet qui est actuellement
extrêmement important pour beaucoup de
gens qui est tabou parce que c'est vrai
que c'est d'ailleurs le fait qu'on
envisage de les poursuivre montrent
qu'il est
il est devenu quasiment impossible de
dire qu'on est contre l'immigration et
ça c'est qu'on doit pouvoir avoir le
droit de parler de l'immigration de de
dire que potentiellement c'est pas un
dogme deux fois 10 m2 que c'est pas une
bénédiction forcément pour la ni pour
les français mais pour ceux qui viennent
du reste qui sont dits racines et on
pourra en parler plus longuement
là je crois que les buzz les gens ont
besoin qu qu'on ose en parler et de voir
cette poursuite
cette sorte d'acharnement contre
génération identitaire est extrêmement
mal perçu moi j'ai été très frappée
parce que la jeune fille une des jeunes
filles qui leur porte parole est passé
sur une émission extrêmement populaire
touche pas à mon poste de animé par
cyril hanouna a été assez rude elle a
été un petit peu bousculé et à la fin on
a fait voter les gens alors ce pas un
sondage c'est pas une élection mais ça
donne quand même eu ni d'une indication
de ce que pensent les gens derrière leur
poste et 65% des ans était contre la
dissolution de génération identitaire
alors ses réserves
c'est plus partagés chez nous au chai de
la gare d'autres à nous sur twitter on
vous pose la question là encore c'est
pas un sondage puisque ce n'est pas un
échantillon représentatif
si ce n'est des gens intelligents qui
suivent les bonnes émissions sur
internet êtes vous pour la dissolution
de génération identitaire c'est non à
52% donc une courte majorité
on a va écouter votre point de vue avec
intérêt le dise pas que jamais avant je
voudrais vous faire entendre
celui de marine le pen qui est contre la
dissolution de génération identitaire au
nom de la liberté d'expression
monsieur darmanin moi la définition que
donne la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme de la liberté d'expression parce
que et ce qu'elle en tire comme
conclusion la cee d âge dit que la
liberté d'expression je lis un veau non
seulement pour les informations les
idées accueillies avec faveur ou
considérées comme inoffensives ou
indifférentes mais aussi pour celles qui
heurtent choquent ou inquiètent l'état
on est pile dans la définition ou une
fraction quelconque de la populace j
smadja je suis résolument pour la
dissolution de génération identitaire
mais il faut donner les bonnes raisons
génération identitaire c'est tout ce que
je déteste du point de vue des idées et
c'est ce qui a fait qu'un jour je
engagés comptent pour lutter contre ça
vraiment c'est tout ce que je déteste
mais c'est pas pour ça qu'il faut
dissoudre génération identitaire n'est
pas pour ça moi vous savez il ya eu un
débat pas si vous venez ya quelques
années il ya eu un débat de savoir s'il
fallait ou pas dissoudre le front
national à l'époque qui est devenu le
rassemblement national j'étais
résolument contre
résolument parce que je considérais que
on va pas faire baisser la température
en cassant le thermomètre
c'est donc ce n'est pas à cause de leurs
idées c'est à cause de ce qu'ils font de
leurs actes et leurs actes sont des
actes délictueux sont des infractions
alors je vais vous en donner plusieurs
quand j'ai les militants de génération
identitaires vont à bobigny en seine
saint denis une ville qui est où il y a
un nombre important d'habitants
plusieurs dizaines de milliers étrangers
ou issus de l'immigration
ils vont sur le toit de la caisse
d'allocations familiales et ils
déploient une banderole où il est écrit
de l'argent pour les français pas pour
les étrangers vous allez à bobigny faire
ça ça c'est un trouble à l'ordre public
ça veut dire que ça ça peut entraîner
des violences ça veut dire que là on est
très exactement dans la définition d'un
article du code de la sécurité publique
qui dit que vous n'avez pas le droit
d'appeler d'inciter à la violence à la
haine envers des personnes pour le seul
motif de leur origine
c'est vraiment ce que dit la loi et
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a rappelé le
ministre à juste titre le miz de
l'intérieur et ça ça justifie
effectivement de de dissoudre génération
deuxième exemple guillaume deuxième
exemple quand j'ai les militants de
génération identitaire déploie comme ils
l'ont fait dans les pyrénées comme ils
l'ont fait il ya deux ans dans les alpes
déploie un grillage ou un filet ou une
barrière pour marquer la frontière ou
pire encore vont dans en mer avec un
bateau pour repousser des migrants
repousser des migrants
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que là il
se substitue aux autorités publiques aux
forces de l'ordre
au travail de la police des douaniers de
la gendarmerie ça c'est interdit par la
loi
donc ça veut dire qu'ils ont franchi à
une jaune alors c est ce que je voudrais
vous réagir sk par un deux poids deux
mesures parce que les associations pro
migrants quand elle s'installe 400
tentes sur la place de la république
c'est totalement illégal quand elles
font passer des gens en fraude des
immigrés clandestins c'est illégal aussi
et pourtant on veut pas les dissoudre ou
l incitation à la haine et la
provocation ou et l'incitation à la
violence
il n'ya pas d'incitation il y a il ya
une situation d'urgence du point de vue
humanitaire et donc on doit juger les
faits là il n'y a pas de voie là mais
s'il ya une urgence humanitaire aussi
vous savez s'il ya une urgence à écouter
ce que ce que ce que disent et pensent
les français vont parler d'incitation à
la haine mois dans la phrase que vous
m'avez donné je vois pas d'incitation à
la haine
donc c'est vrai qu aller c'est-à-dire
non environnants de bobigny finalement
l'argent que vous toucher des
allocations familiales donne une opinion
au dessus on c'est une blague une
allocation fabiano cartiaux foetus
provocateur la sexualité c'est une
provocation ça ça a bloqué appelée
islamophobie ou dire que j'ai pas si
vous avez dit non non non il viendra
lobby alors non non ça c'est une
incitation aux phobies c'est une
incitation à la haine à la violence et à
la discrimination oui à la menace dit
que c'est contre les étrangers je répète
ce que vous avez dit précédemment donc
je traduis sans accuser nos phobies et
bien d'une phrase qui est somme toute
assez anodine et qui trouvaient
peut-être avoir un certain nombre oui
monsieur moi je crois qu'il faut pas il
faut pas dans la politique de
l'indignation
il faut être dans l'analyse et et dans
le comment dire l'argumentation
vous savez très bien que par exemple
quand le juge charles prades as a publié
son livre sur les fraudes sociales
quand il ya des émissions sur ce sujet
eh bien il ya des français derrière leur
poste de télévision qui se disaient
qu'ils ont droit de se dire je dis ça
parce que vous parlez de la caisse
d'allocations familiales sinon ce n'est
pas le sujet initial qui peuvent se dire
mais comment se fait-il qu'on lui pas
contre ces fraudes alors qu'on sait que
ça dernier voir notamment
voir mais non vous d'urgence humanitaire
mouvement humanitaire état est pas
exactement adapté mais il ya une urgence
à se préoccuper de ces questions là
parce que il ya beaucoup de français
avec abonnés oui mais vous savez bien
avec nous et non seulement alerte pour
précisément que le gouvernement s'en
préoccuper il ya beaucoup de français
qui se sentent abandonnés pression vous
avez des gens qui décident
je vous avais d ailleurs pour revenir au
sujet initial des frontières vous savez
très bien que ce n'est pas neutre parce
que le terroriste de nice il est passé
peut-être par l'une de ses frontières
que par les amis exactement donc ça
c'est génération identitaire il va
empêcher ça sinon laisser importer dans
un milices privées on a aujourd'hui un
soir titulaire
je ne crois pas qu'ils se substituent
les policiers pour les prévenir donc
c'est tout quand ils vont en meilleure
qu'avant mercosur on va chercher des
migrants de l'autre semaine il est un
vrai festival de cannes une incitation à
la haine et l'incitation illégal mais il
voit l'un des gardiens en fait il ya il
ya des seize associations qui font des
choses illégales et que l'on remercie
que l'on invite mai au festival de
cannes
et puis à des associations qui demandent
que la loi soit respectée et qui elles
sont condamnées que l'on menace de
dissoudre
comment voulez vous que cela ne révolte
pas les français les vous que je vous
livre quelques commentaires
d'internautes qui sont presque aussi
passionné que vous sur ce sujet nadia
sur youtube je suis contre toutes les
formes d'extrémisme d'où qu'ils viennent
ceux qui brûlent les voitures comme
génération identitaire donc voilà je
savais pas cette information mais enfin
voila je vous la livre
ça veut dire je pense qu'il faudrait
c'est peut-être à ce moment-là je pense
qu'il faut que chacun se calment et
médite sur ce que je crois être
important de la bienveillance d'un côté
et de la justice de l'autre anne sur
twitter qui considère qu arrêter un
mouvement politique par la force accroît
son soutien jean et jacques sur twitter
la cabale contre génération identitaire
est purement politique pour faire
oublier les échecs darmana et du
gouvernement
thomas sur twitter qui dit si c'est pour
dissoudre une association et retrouver
ses membres dans les réserves de la
police cela ne sert à rien voilà je
rappelle que gérard lamanda a décidé
d'augmenter le nombre de réservistes
dans la police nationale
ako buzz qui soutient plutôt jeunes ne
font rien d'illégal affirme-t-il sur
youtube ils avertissent l'opinion
publique alors pourquoi dissoudre une
association qui respectent la loi puis
on a énormément de commentaires je peux
pas tous vous les donner mais merci à
vous de participer à la fois sur youtube
sur lefigaro.fr et sur twitter cette
dissolution de dre cinq points de plus à
marine le pen en 2022 estime philippe
quand vive paris sur youtube et la
démocratie alors les extrêmes aussi ont
le droit d'exister et de s'exprimer
et puis kris kross sur lefigaro.fr
occupez vous plutôt des black blocks
est ce que j smadja c'est pas une
effectivement une façon de laisser
sortir la pression de ne pas dissoudre
ce genre d'organisme un petit peu comme
le raisonnement que vous teniez sur le
front national en disant qu'il fallait
pas le 10 autres parce que on casser le
thermomètre est ce que génération
identitaire ça n'est pas aussi un terme
dans génération identitaires ne fait
avancer aucun débat absolument je le
réfute totalement cette qualificative de
lanceurs d alerte
aucun débat génération identitaire ils
commettent des actes qui sont des actes
qui sont punis par la loi
si si si ils sont punis par la loi
c'est ça c'est le rôle d'un c'est le
rôle d'un état à un moment donné de
fixer des limites
alors on le sait le rôle d'un état alors
que qu'il ya eu un jugement qu'il aurait
été un premier jugement leur a été
défavorable
et c'est en appel qui veulent vraiment
là qu'il a été qu'ils nous ont été
relaxés le premier jugement les a
condamnés donc c'est le rôle d'un état
de saisir la justice chaque fois qu'on
estime que la ligne jaune a été franchie
en l'occurrence là elle est franchie on
va les petits je ne suis pas le seul à
le dire il ya beaucoup de juristes qui
l'oeil qu'il affirme
à part vous mais moi je veux cloud n'est
pas daté n'a jamais laissé sa part les
huit minutes est pas là vous n'êtes pas
d'accord était pas le sujet de
l'immigration si vous dormez dollarisée
vous voulez entendre mais moi je
voudrais génération la dentine ne reçoit
pas vous repensez bien sûr mais non mais
c'est leur faire baisser leur faire
beaucoup d'honneur on allait leur faire
trop d'honneur voire d'ailleurs dans la
crise sanitaire nos frontières n'était
pas un gros mot refusé et comment dire
évacuer cette question en la
criminalisant de l'immigration et du
naufrage du tabac soir si vous voulez y
ont déjà vu un nouveau point de vue où
vous mettez le fait qu'une étoile à en
liaison avec l'actualité mais dès que
l'immigration revient dans l'actualité
je suis prêt à revenir et ans par mois
d'ici très donc il n'y a pas de sujet là
tu sais pas ça le problème
je sais bien mais on en fait le problème
des faits que vous donnez à génération
donnée
nous voulons vous donner un mouvement
fascisant une vertu elle n'a absolument
pas c'est à dire le fait qu'il est là
pour poser des débats dans les de la
débâcle et non pas du tout c'est un
mouvement kach exemple oui alors en tout
cas ce qui est certain c'est que
puisqu'il ya une enquête préliminaire
on va voir ce que ça donne
judiciairement merci en tout cas d'avoir
accepté de débattre sur ce sujet malgré
des désaccords qui me semble assez nette
une dernière question gabriel cluzel
j'ai vu passer un nouveau tweet là vous
avez des problèmes avec twitter qu'est
ce qui se passe dit abbas et c'était à
c'était presque risible même si c'est
quand même assez ennuyeux c'est à dire
donc je le cite boulevard voltaire dont
vous êtes là exactement ce matin se
réveillait en découvrant que le compte
twitter a été suspendu je vous le donne
en mille parce que il a comme sur sa
bannière c'est la bannière c'est la
photo qu'on a sur l'homme sur son profil
et il y à la liberté mène les guides le
peuple le fameux tableau d'eugène
delacroix qui était sur les billets de
100 francs pour les plus vieux des
fusions tableau eh bien il a été jugé
par twitter comme violant les règles de
2,2 twitter parmi les changements on
imagine voilà il a été jugé choquant
c'est vrai ctions si on ne sortent du
contexte culturel c'est une femme
exhibitionniste qui incitent à la
violence qu'elle est armé mais voyez ou
3 700 / peut nous mener
bon là alors messahel ses revenus depuis
votre compte est suspendu alors suspendu
alors on va tout faire pour vous des
verts j'ai peut-être nay et j'imagine
comme ça pour faire un saut sur toi mais
les responsables de twitter au louvre
couleurs la matérialité que le louvre
sera rouvert en y emmenant vers elle
pour ça merci beaucoup à tous les deux
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis merci
[Musique]